I know that you do CrossFit and you are
very physically fit and then I found out
today that you have a a code name at
CrossFit is that right
no somebody well you know when someone
calls you like a ginger they don't
usually mean it as like a compliment
I thought they meant it as a compliment
not like that really hot dude with red
hair but like a ginger okay why isn't it
possible that someone could find a dude
really hot with red hair let's drop this
subject no I know what you mean okay so
what so what somebody I might because
I'm new and like you know I getting my
calluses like a big girl but my hands
rips up really bad and somebody judging
me referred to me as a ginger flower I
was like four stars what in God's name
is a ginger flower right because that
does not sound like a compliment right I
like sound like something that when
you're learning with people who can lift
like massively heavy things that you
want to be and it was like something
about being like handled really
delicately and being kind of fragile
which if you relate to it was my
nickname in high school
I'll teach you wisdom do you need to be
handled carefully yes I do
I don't need to much nicer to you yes
yes you do yes I'm extremely sensitive
hyper sensitive okay
I'll be ready to go Joel said very cruel
things about me and my trip to Italy and
so I hurt my feelings
you